No civilized person wants to live in a society without a lot of privacy in it.
Supreme Court nominee Robert Bork's 1987 confirmation hearings changed everything—
maybe forever. According to lawyer and Supreme Court blogger Tom Goldstein,
"because they legitimize the scorched earth ideological wars that have since become the norm."
After the Senate rejected Bork, President Reagan turned to a 41 year old judge named Douglas H Ginsburg,
a recent appointee to the Court of Appeals for D.C. who, unlike Bork,
didn't have a long judicial record for the Senate to pick over. It wasn't to be.
Yesterday the nominee for the U.S. Supreme Court
admitted he smoked marijuana once in the 1960s and a few times in the 70's that led to talk with drawl.
I have today asked President Reagan not to forward my nomination to the Supreme Court.
Ginsburg withdrew his name for consideration and Justice Anthony Kennedy ended up filling the vacancy.
Over the next three decades,
Judge Ginsburg built a reputation as one of the most influential and principled champions of originalism,
a legal theory that emphasizes close adherence to the text of the law,
and the explicit intentions of the legislators at the time laws are passed.
Now a senior judge on the D.C. Circuit Court of Appeals,
and a professor at George Mason University's Law School,
Ginsburg stars in the forthcoming PBS series, A More or Less Perfect Union,"
his personal exploration of the history and future of the Constitution in American life.
These documents are the charters of freedom and freedom is what the United States is all about.
The Constitution is really perhaps the greatest secular document ever written.
We don't have a religion, you don't have an ethnicity, we have a Constitution.
It's the law of laws. It's idiot-proof and we
have tested that over and over again.
I sat down with Ginsberg to discuss his
new show and its companion book,
"Why the Impeachment Proceedings Against Donald Trump are in No Way a Constitutional Crisis,"
his opinions of Neil Gorsuch and Brett Kavanaugh, whether it's possible to rein in the administrative state,
and why he has never regretted pulling his name for the Supreme Court 32 years ago.
Douglas Ginsburg, thanks for talking to Reason. Glad to be here. Let's talk about "A More or Less Perfect Union,"
a personal exploration this is your
statement and about the Constitution
what's the controlling idea or the main
threat running through the series well
it's that the history of the
Constitution has been one of fits and
starts in extending Liberty to more and
more people freedoms and protecting them
fits and starts and occasional reversals
sometimes enormous reversals and the
liberties that are protected by our
Constitution are fragile and easily lost
what's an example of you know a moment
of reversal and a fragile Liberty that
was lost or or you think is most
imperiled right well though we're the
most extreme example of reversal and it
was the Dred Scott decision in which the
Supreme Court made up a right to own
slaves and made it impossible for a
former slave ever to become a citizen
which could only have expedited the
course towards civil war and it was
totally fanciful I mean that when the
Supreme Court as either excised
provisions from the Constitution or
supplemented new ones of its own making
the results are not good the
Constitution is better left as it was as
it was written today we see speakers
being intimidated disinvited or shouted
down on campuses including public
universities which are subject to the
Constitution and that's that's a very
dangerous trend would you say just
speaking about the First Amendment or at
which I guess it you know it's both the
right of assembly but then also
obviously free speech is our kind of
understanding of it now or what's what's
imperiled that's actually a fairly
recent understanding of the First
Amendment of I mean free speech really
kind of broad-based going back to maybe
the 50s or 60s where I mean there were
books that were censored politicians
could sue newspapers for defamation
things like that well their First
Amendment didn't really
have its debut in the Supreme Court
until the first world war and the Red
Scare the their suppression through the
post office of magazines on the
left-wing magazines and that sort of
thing so it did start a bit awkwardly in
the first few instances actually the
censorship was upheld but rather quickly
became the most important assurance of
our democracy that that we have and it
kept on growing you're right that even
in the 50s there were cases involving
local censorship indeed even later on
for obscenity or pornography and but the
Supreme Court has really made it now I
would say impossible to sanction someone
for speech or writing of any sort other
than possibly graphics and I think
that's a great thing do you feel an
added sense of urgency to all of this
right now I mean is it is it because
you're at a certain point in your life
or do that you're worried about the
stuff going away or do you think the
country is actually in a perilous state
well the country is always in a perilous
state or at least the Constitution is
because liberties are inherently fragile
the normal state of human beings is not
to be prosperous and and free the way we
are and once lost those things are very
very hard to regain so there have been
other times in our history which were
more perilous perhaps but it's always a
concern always should be a concern and
as I mentioned the example of what's
going on now with with free speech
that's one but our politics have
similarly become censorious and divisive
in a way that is not healthy for the
Constitution you are interested in in
the legal doctrine called originalism
what is that and why is it so important
well it's a very simple proposition we
were given a written constitution
and as Chief Justice Marshall said in
1803 the virtue of that is one can hold
up a law or an executive action to the
Constitution and determine whether it
was authorized because all of the powers
are listed there and we have pampered me
we have with the supreme court's
permission approval drifted very far
from the Constitution we were given the
legislature the Congress has delegated
enormous amounts of power to the
executive through creating agencies that
are given a very broad mandate to
regulate quote in the public interest
close quote to achieve clean water or
clean air or whatever the goal so the
the they escape responsibility they have
this broad delegation and when things
are inevitably made hard for some
portion of the citizenry and they want
relief they write to their congressman
and the congressman says well I'll
intervene with the agency I'll write
them a letter so they get the benefit of
saying I voted for clean air and then
later on I helped you when your factory
was in trouble this is not so yes so the
way the root of the issue which is the
abrogation or abnegation of
responsibility by Congress to actually
pass legislation that defines agents so
the agencies enacted in the last
Congress 3100 and some regulations that
have the force of law and the Congress
passed 118 as many laws so 18 out of
every 19 laws was basically passed by an
agency not by democratically elected
members of the Congress not subject to
bicameralism not subject to even
presidential signature so is originalism
fundamentally about the administrative
state or well it's certainly it's
certainly true that the administrative
state could not exist in the way that it
does if we were true to the Constitution
I mean you're one of the kind of
scholars and I you know I guess both
architects but also proponents and
practitioners of original
you know through your rulings on the on
the court as well as your writings as a
law professor and scholar you know when
did originalism start as a school of
thought and do youth has it been
successful because in many ways it has
been I mean you guys matter in in legal
discourse in a way that nobody was
talking about this 20 30 40 years ago so
when did it start and is it working
there were earlier outcroppings and
among academic lawyers but the real
demarcation I would say was in 1985 or
1984 when Attorney General Meese Akos 85
spoke to the American Bar Association
and gave a talk called a jurisprudence
of original intent and justice Brennan
answered that with an article in the
Georgetown Law Review talking about a
living Constitution now original intent
was quickly realized I think that we
don't know what people intend we know
what they wrote and so it's an original
meaning not in public meeting what
people understood when they ratified the
Constitution so the original meaning
versus a living Constitution what makes
a Constitution living well what they
mean but justice Brennan meant with
scholars since then mean is that it's
quite adaptable by of course five out of
nine justices of the Supreme Court to
meet the needs of their perceived needs
of the moment and originalism is saying
adhere to the Constitution it can be
amended if the if the contemporary needs
really cannot be met but the principles
that are there are actually enduring and
are sufficient and I think almost every
instance so you know in one of the
conversations that's going on or
problems that is gonna be faced in the
courts is having to do with
anti-discrimination statutes that were
passed in the 60s saying you can't
discriminate against people based on
gender on religion on race it's actually
so sex okay sex yeah thank you yeah well
that's important because what I was
going to say is that now
you know one of the issues is should
sexual orientation which nobody was
really thinking about back then should
that be covered by anti-discrimination
statutes and with that from an
originalist point of view would that
require a new law being written or is
that seen as okay that's kind of
embedded in the original meaning of what
was passed well as to whether it's
covered by the current statutes that's
something that might have welcomed
before my court
I really shouldn't address that as to as
to whether it should be and that at
worst that would require another statute
it certainly isn't a constitutional
requirement to use you do you think I'm
one of the reasons why some people push
back against originalism is I mean it
really does limit the power of the
government you know whether it's a
bureaucracy or Congress or whatever to
just say oh now well we don't have to
pass a new law we'll just start doing
that is part of the reason why people
push back on originalism is it would
require people in Congress right now on
whatever the issue is to say yes we
should be doing this or that and they
just want to escape responsibility well
certainly that's why a member of
Congress would push back because it's
lovely it being able to say I voted for
clean air and not have to take
responsibility for the actual
consequences and I think there's a
misconception among others not elected
officials that that originalism would
somehow leave some people unprotected by
the Constitution I mean that's we're not
talking about a constitution that was
never amended we had the Civil War
amendments which protect not only the
former slaves but everyone from racial
discrimination it says persons it
doesn't say all men are created equal
it's persons now that it still leaves
room for it for the Supreme Court to say
in what dimensions is equal treatment
required because things that our
difference that can be can be treated
differently but that is just not a not a
problem with originalism is originalism
inherently libertarian
sense that it restricts the power of the
arbitrary power of the state or well we
might agree is the arbitrary power of
the state it's inherently libertarian to
the the framers set out to protect some
liberties and the original Constitution
and the Bill of Rights that were quickly
added and the Civil War amendments and
other amendments protect those liberties
and embellishing that can only diminish
them what is your sense you know in
talking about kind of the administrative
state or the willingness of Congress to
just say okay you go you know we're
gonna pass a very we're gonna pass a law
in favor of clean air you guys go figure
it out Donald Trump Steve ban and his
former adviser said famously that Donald
Trump wanted to deconstruct the
administrative state and yet at the same
time I mean which in a way takes power
away from the executive branch because
it's like no Congress really is calling
the shots here at the same time that
Donald Trump seems to be a critic of the
administrative state he also embodies a
kind of imperial presidency it has he
been good in terms of winnowing down the
administrative state first let me say
that the pen the Congress created to the
extent we have an imperial presidency
it's because of delegations by the
Congress President Nixon was actually
within the law when he imposed wage and
price controls on the entire country for
a brief period of time President Trump
was in within the law when he imposed
tariffs the Congress delegated these
huge authorities probably thinking they
would be used only in a true emergency
which is not what's happened that's a
problem of the another problem of this
constant delegation of authority and
escaping responsibility consider the
Iran deal remember when President Obama
entered into this agreement with Iran
did you hear any senators saying wait a
minute that's a treaty we ought to be
voting on that no I didn't I don't
recall anybody that's because it's
easier for them to either agree with it
or nitpick or say well there's nothing
we can do about it the rounding out
their text it you won't see I suppose so
but you know they don't they didn't
stand up and say we need to vote on this
one way or the other
do you feel and I'm just gonna make you
uncomfortable as I can obviously you're
very skilled at not being uncomfortable
but do you think Trump's Supreme Court
pick so far
Neil Gorsuch and Brett Kavanaugh are
they are they good for your vision of
the Constitution I think they are they
are likely to be I think we will be true
to the to the text of the Constitution
Neil was a student of mine and of course
at Harvard and Brett was my colleague
for 12 years on the court I've worked
with him in a lot of things they're both
very scholarly I think they're both
committed to originalism I certainly
hope so
Justice Scalia was although he called
himself a faint-hearted originalist and
did depart and an occasion or two but
that remains to be seen how with it
whether we have the others again right
of growing and when you're on the
Supreme Court right and all sorts of
weird and wonderful ways well the
growing seems to be always a tropism
pulling to the left and so that's called
growth by the new york times but it
might be called decadence by you know by
someone else Brett Kavanaugh as your
colleague do you have any reason to
question his his version of events about
sexual harassment I came out in his
hearing I have no reason to doubt that
yeah
here is a process question we want the
law to be transparent and known and all
of that do you think as a matter of
practice Donald Trump did something that
was kind of rare for presidents and that
he put out a public shortlist of people
that he was considering for the Supreme
Court independent of who's on that list
or whatever is that a good idea or a bad
idea as far as I know it was the first
time any presidential candidate has done
that and insofar as it informed voters
about what they're getting I can hardly
think it's anything but a good idea
presidential candidates make all sorts
of promises on which they can't deliver
and one of the things the president can
do is choose a point he's not just for
the Supreme Court or the courts
whole but for the administrative
agencies for the departments that are
directly in the cabinet and directly
report to the president and the more
people know about what the
president-elect is actually going to do
I think the more informed their voting
Congress is refusing to take
responsibility for a lot of what it does
right the impeachment process is
something different than that and again
this is independent of the particular x'
we throw around the idea that there's a
constitutional crisis always I mean that
gets bandied about a lot whenever
anybody feels like their vision of
whatever they want America to be isn't
isn't being pursued or followed does the
impeachment process as it's kind of
rolling out right now does that worry
you at all in terms of serious
constitutional problems or is it
proceeding according to the way that it
should be doing first of all I say it
seems that in recent years the United
States is a country without problems it
has only crises if everything is
inflated into a crisis by the news media
in fact I don't think we've had any
crises in in my lifetime as for the the
current events there are precedents
about how this proceedings should be
handled and there's a dispute now
between the parties I guess in the
Congress as to whether those precedents
are being followed or not that's not
going to be justiciable it's not going
to come before a court and I certainly
shouldn't be gratuitous Leo pining on it
right yeah but if it were to come before
the court again I wouldn't speak to it
okay I thought it could I could have to
address it in court but it's a it's a
dispute between political branches do
you you know as as somebody who is
against who is generally in favor of
restraining government or and also the
executive or how about preserving
Liberty okay very good that's it's a
positive way of saying it right
when you look at the presidents who have
been who have faced impeachment
proceedings Nixon resigned before he was
technically impeach but it was in the
cards Clinton obviously happened Trump
now it may or may not we don't know if
it's going to actually reach fruition
but the idea
when when President Trump says or a
president says to Congress I'm not going
to give you the information the
documents I'm not going to cooperate
with something is that problematic I
actually do have a case on that okay so
you're seven members of the House
Oversight Committee are seeking
documents from an executive agency
because they would reflect on the
president right and is this the taxes
tax returns or no it has to do with the
hotel okay they want some information
right if the president the
administration has not given it the
cases and argued and we're now it's
under consider because the Second
Circuit just rule or is going to have
just ruled on a case about whether or
not
Trump's lawyers have to turn over tax
documents related to questions about
funding of the 2016 campaign okay okay
all right well different circle you must
be really hard when you don't want to
order at dinner you can just say you
know I might have a case that rolls in
that say what I want I'm not sure
whether it's the Second Circuit or the
state court in New York you're not
worried that right now any any thing
going on in America you know in in DC
which is a very hyperbolic you know
polarized environment there are real
controversies and wrote disagreements
about what should be being done but
nothing has risen to the level of a true
constitutional crisis well that's right
and when it did when we had the
president nixon's resistance to turning
over and they're finally turning over
the tapes the crisis is you know is
resolved I mean what people are arguing
about for the most part is about the law
right what is the law require as long as
we're arguing about the law we're not in
a crisis because everyone's got a view
but ultimately they're trying to follow
or invoke the law why do you think
Congress or was there a moment where
Congress just said you know what we're
not going to do our job we're gonna push
it over someplace else
or was that a gradual and kind of
intermittent process and
I guess as importantly how do we how do
we change that well the the real
discontinuity occurred in the New Deal
when the Congress passed one after
another regulatory statute bringing
large sectors of the economy under
federal regulation I mean agriculture
transportation communication finance
transportation and assigned to all the
regulations who these new newly created
agencies and the Supreme Court upheld
that and so the that set the precedent
and the Congress has continued to do
that in the 1970s it created under
President Nixon created a number of
statutes that regulate not the economy
but risk so the Consumer Product Safety
Commission the Occupational Safety and
Health Act the Mine Safety and Health
Act the Traffic Safety Act Highway
Safety Act rather the Environmental
Protection Act so these are our
different in kind but they're similar in
that there's this huge delegation of
authority the economic regulations been
almost entirely repealed it was realized
that that was it was contrary to the
well being of the public it was
anti-consumer and that's something I've
heard you speak recently about that's
one of the great things about the D
regulations in the 70s is that you had
people like Ralph Nader and Ted Kennedy
along with kind of right-wing
free-market conservatives all saying
yeah this stuff isn't working right yeah
I mean the back basically it was
academics who demonstrated it
empirically it just wasn't working and
what we have now with risk regulation is
a much more challenging matter because
you can't just repeal it I mean there
are real hazards out there then they
have to be dealt with and the question
is how how to do it how best to do it
and with the environment is the classic
example the problem is for the most part
absence of property rights and where the
government can create property rights
the right to emit a certain quantity of
pollution and no more and those can be
traded back and forth the problem gets
solved in a much more efficient way than
saying you have to use this particular
technology or equipment or what
are you worried in a broader sense that
you know property rights are good
markets are good but right now we're
living in a moment where markets are
held in a pretty low standing by a lot
of people partly because of the 2008
financial crisis partly because of a
resurgence of a belief in socialism that
capitalism is kind of red and tooth and
claw and it's a nasty business and that
we have enough wealth that we can share
is it is it a bad time if if markets are
the solution to many risk factors
particularly environmental pollution is
this like the worst possible time to be
kind of arguing in favor of markets for
remedy well it's probably the most
important time to be doing so generation
has grown up that thinks that all of
this prosperity grows on trees it
doesn't it had to be created in an
environment that nurtured it and one of
economic freedom that's the only way in
which that can happen we know that at
least those of us who have witnessed
what happened with socialism and it's
happening again it's happening in
Venezuela and other places and
impoverishes and enslaved people and
young people just have not lived through
that and don't seem to be studying it in
the serious way so it's important that
they be rescued from that ignorant and
to see that the the only solution is one
in which we have free markets and free
people thinking about the the recent
past really I mean the end of communism
you had mentioned the argument between
ed meese and justice brennan Nevada you
know original intent versus living
Constitution you of course played a part
in this history as well of a
hyperpolarized kind of political
environment in 1987 you were nominated
to the Supreme Court not quite the
president said he wouldn't have me I
felt a yes yes okay that will get but in
Robert Bork have been nominated gone
through a very fractious confirmation
process was ultimately voted it was not
voted in or he was not his but the vote
didn't go his way you were nominated or
rather your name was put forward and
then it came out
you are you openly admitted that you had
smoked marijuana and that caused a just
a kind of freak app didn't it and and
kind of the way people talked about
things well very briefly and that it
turned out that a lot of members of the
Senate and others came forward and said
well I did that too and it was a while
ago as it was for me yeah there was the
temper at the times and all is forgiven
so before we get to the larger legal
framework what what does it say is it a
good thing in American society now that
you know the three president you know
President Clinton Bush and Obama all
have openly admitted to various kinds of
illicit drug use and whatnot and it
hasn't just it didn't destroy their
careers they may not have been very good
presidents but nobody was blaming it on
drugs are we in a better place in terms
of discussion of kind of lifestyle
choices drug use things like that than
we were 35 years ago I don't know
certainly I certainly don't think we're
at a better place in terms of of so many
people using drugs right it's at what do
you mean by that well apparently there
are a lot of people who are using
illegal drugs that are harmful to their
health and and and you know in states
that have legalized marijuana for one or
either for medical years or more that's
inconsistent with federal law I don't
know how an industry can grow can grow
up where if the federal government could
start enforcing that law any day seem
like a rather perilous
proposition I well I think that it hurts
the industry certainly right because it
it can be wiped out
you know overnight are you in favor of
reducing federal prohibitions on things
like marijuana cultivation and
distribution and possession and states
that have made it legal well it's that
turns out to be a more complex question
than I had thought
perhaps
many years ago my understanding is now
that because marijuana legalized in many
of the western states the source
producers have switched to selling hard
drugs heroin in particular because
they've lost much of their or at least
their profits gone out of the marijuana
well that's not a happy consequence we
were certainly unanticipated no one that
I know ever anticipated that but if you
look so if you look at the net
consequences you have to take that into
into effect into account as well more
people being addicted to heroin not good
when it comes to the larger kind of
social political legal framework or way
that we talk about stuff the vorc
hearings were some people say that was
the moment where America really in
politics became hyperpolarized hyper
hyper tribe tribalistic or that was the
starting point do you agree with that I
agree with it insofar as we're talking
about Supreme Court nominations that had
never been handled like that before
there wasn't a there wasn't a hearing
the nominee wasn't called to Washington
to appear before committee until I think
sometime in the 1940s and when I think
it was Justice frankfurter came down
he'd sat outside the committee room
waited and then was told he could go
home so and that was before the era of
television of course but the Bork
hearings really polarized the the
process and in a way that each each of
the parties in turn seems to think they
have to retaliate and it just escalates
and it's become the most recent round it
was just I can't imagine how it could
get any worse but it likely will right
well X because with each replacement it
seems like this stakes get higher and
well people will we'll try to think of
something even worse than accusing a
nominee of rape you know when it turns
out to be fictitious
now you by the way do you know that one
of the accusers said she's just one of
the attention hmm yeah so do you
withdraw
do you regret withdrawing your name from
consideration not really I've had a good
career on the circuit I I'd know I've
known almost all of the justices since
then most of them pretty well and I
wouldn't want the security concerns that
they've have it's really unfortunate
particularly the last 20 years of 18
years that that they have to be
concerned about security like that do
you see that is partly reflecting
Congress again kind of withdrawing from
doing what it's supposed to be doing I
mean if Congress isn't actually passing
laws it seems you know the Supreme Court
becomes more important in many ways I
think the Supreme Court became more
important because it discarded fidelity
to the text and to started engaging in
moral philosophy instead of law and when
you have 5-4 decisions on highly
divisive moral questions for which there
is not a textual good textual warrant it
makes it very divisive what's a good
example of of that decision at that type
of decision well Roe versus Wade
obergefell they get a marriage case I
don't disagree necessarily with those
outcomes but they're not federal within
the federal authority so what should
have happened saying in roe v wade well
i think about 12 state this was the
height of the women's movement her first
wave about 12 states I think had changed
their laws a few probably had considered
a knot on the rest were yet to do so
got to consider and decide what to do
and similarly with with same-sex
marriage the states were going along the
Iowa Supreme Court held that it was a
matter of a constitutional right under
the Iowa Constitution and at the next
election I think three of the four
judges in that majority were not
re-elected because the people there
disagreed with that it was coming out
different ways in different states and
that was not an untenable matter but
most important it was a process that was
legitimate
there's a lovely book by Marianne
Glendon called divorce and abortion or
abortion divorce in Western law and it's
a comparative study of 23 countries and
22 countries resolved the abortion
matter by statute and one by judicial
Fiat and you don't see demonstrations
all over the place in those 22 countries
because when there's a legislative
resolution it's not somebody wins and
somebody loses which it is in court its
compromise is necessary
can I ask from a libertarian perspective
either from my love my understanding of
libertarian perspective we wouldn't say
or you know in a way you're saying okay
these really tough moral issues or
cultural issues are being worked out
abortion gay married or same-sex
marriage and you know part of what
you're saying is that it'll be worked
out through legislatures so we need to
give it time
to kind of find its way but then you
know you think about if it was free
speech you wouldn't say well you know
what Iowa wants to ban certain types of
free speech well you know we'll let that
go because you can you can move to
Minnesota and have free speech or
something but it's not because of
federalism and being able to move from
one state to another it's because free
speech is specifically protected so it
is I mean when when things are
enumerated they're enumerated for a
written constitution you know that
question so something like abortion
something like marriage these just don't
right I mean they are not something that
should be decided by the federal
judiciary for the most part not decided
on the merits no they should have been
should've said this is this is not a
matter to which our Constitution speaks
the Federal Constitution go home and
deal with your state legislature what or
the state courts how would I and I think
we have a sense of it but how would if
if you had been on the Supreme Court how
would a Ginsburg court have you know
have been different than the one that
we've that we've encountered for the
past you know three or four decades
well I think I've just told you at least
a couple of important examples here's
some here's another one about it about
ten years ago in a case called kylo
against New London the city decided to
condemn property in order to turn it
over to a developer for revitalization
of the downtown area or the neighborhood
and missus kilo didn't want her property
taken for that it went to the Supreme
Court and the court the the relevant
provision of the Constitution says the
property may be taken for a public use
with just compensation and a public use
was pretty well understood that meant a
highway a post office a school of public
use and the Supreme Court said well this
is a public purpose that's good enough
it's a public purpose we know that
because the public body this town
council voted for it
well that's rewriting the Constitution
it doesn't say a public purpose and
that's an interesting decision because
it's not simply you know kind of
conservative versus liberal say about 40
states very quickly either by statute or
Court decision said we're not doing that
so we wouldn't if your property is
secure but so that might not have
happened or it might not have had to
have happened had you been on the
Supreme well I certainly wouldn't have
agreed with it I don't remember for his
5'4 I think it probably was you know to
bring it back to your forthcoming series
on the Constitution Oh more or less
perfect Union personal discovery part of
what's interesting is that you talk to a
lot of different types of people both
you know kind of professional thinkers
on the Constitution but then regular
people what you know in going through
that you know are you are you optimistic
that you know that we're in pretty good
shape or are you really like oh my god
this is like we're just screwed here
well I wouldn't have made the effort if
I thought it was goodness and I wouldn't
have made the effort if I thought it was
needless right so I think there is I
want the public at least the public
television on a part of the public to be
aware of a debate that's extremely
important
to our Republic it's a debate that
occurs in law schools and on courts and
need more public engagement more public
awareness I don't think the public would
support some of the creativity that
they're fact that they're getting from
the courts are some of the lassitude
from the legislature if they were more
familiar with it you know what is it
beyond your series is there a go to text
or book or document or movie that you
know thick I'm glad you asked that
there's a companion volume called voices
of our Republic which has things that
people have written about the
Constitution or said mostly for the book
but some of them are a few historical
quotations justice O'Connor
Justice Ginsburg Justice Gorsuch and and
I think a couple of others have all
contributed to the book with their
thoughts and there's some material about
the making of the series in there as
well
so we're optimistic that that will help
get the the message across just as the
TV show does that this is an important
topic as Randy Barnett says in the show
the only living Constitution is one
that's followed but that names been
appropriated well we will leave it there
talking with Judge Douglas Ginsberg
thank you so much thank you an extra
heavy appreciate it for a reason I'm
Nick Gillespie